WELCOME BACK.
CORONAVIRUS IS BAD ENOUGH SO
HERE’S A QUESTION, WHY WOULD
ANYONE WANT TO MAKE OUT WITH
ITS WORSE THAN WHAT IT IS.
>> AMERICA IS THE LARGEST
CORONAVIRUS DISASTER IN THE
WORLD BY A MILLION MILES.
TO TRY TO PROVE THIS CLAIM SHE
SHOWED THIS GRAPHIC OF CASES,
THAT HELPFUL LITTLE RED ARROW
TO SHOW YOU JUST HOW BAD IT
IS.
AMERICA’S POPULATION IS BIGGER
THAN ALL THOSE COUNTRIES PUT
TOGETHER, EVEN THOUGH NEW YORK
TIMES ISN’T THAT DECEPTIVE.
THEY SAID A BETTER COMPARISON
IS ON WESTERN EUROPEAN AND ON
THAT CASES THERE’S MANY MORE
CASES NOT RUN BY TRUMP BUT
EVEN THAT’S NOT THE WHOLE
PICTURE BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
CASES ACTUALLY MEASURES THE
NUMBER OF TESTS SO WHY DON’T
WE COMPARE WHAT REALLY
MATTERS, HOW MANY LIVES ARE
BEING LOST.
THERE IS THE ACTUAL DATA.
JOHNS HOPKINS, DEATHS.
100,000, AMERICA HAS THE LEAST
BAD OUTBREAK THAN ANY COUNTRY
APART FROM GERMANY.
IF YOU TAKE THE NEW YORK METRO
AREA, THE REST OF AMERICA’S
CLOSE.
[INAUDIBLE]
IT’S ABOUT TESTING.
>> IT JUST SHOWS HOW FAR WE
ARE BEHIND IN TERMS OF TESTING
AND TRACING.
BEHIND TWO?
WE TEST MORE THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE BY FAR, A RATE OF A
MILLION TESTS A DAY IS NOT
EVEN CLOSE.
ON TEST FOR POPULATION WE ARE
AHEAD OF SOUTH KOREA WHO HAS
BEEN CONSIDERED THE GOLD
STANDARD AND THAT’S AFTER THE
BUNGLING OF THE MEDIAS SECTOR
THE CDC.
[INAUDIBLE]
IS NOT JUST THAT, IT’S THE
FEAR MONGERS WEEK AFTER WEEK
AFTER ASSUMING THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN NEW YORK WAS THE
SAME AS EVERYONE ELSE’S.
NOW TRY TO FRIGHTEN THE REST
OF AMERICA WITH MISINFORMATION
ABOUT THE DISASTER IN PLACES
LIKE MEATPACKING PLANTS IN
SIOUX FALLS SOUTH DAKOTA.
>> SOUTH DAKOTA.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR CHRISTIE
STILL REFUSES TO ISSUE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
>> SOUTH DAKOTA GIVES US A
GOOD WINDOW INTO WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IF A GOVERNOR THERE
DIDN’T PUT INTO EFFECT A STAY
AT HOME ORDER.
>> I DON’T THINK THEY’VE EVER
PAID SO MUCH ATTENTION TO RED
STATE AMERICA IN THEIR LIVES,
BUT NOW THEY CAN TERRIFY THEM,
THEY’RE ALL IN.
I CHECKED THE DATA ON THE
DEADLIEST CORONAVIRUS DAY IN
SOUTH DAKOTA, FIVE PEOPLE
DIED.
FIVE FAMILY TRAGEDIES, BUT THE
NUMBER WAS FIVE.
DEATHS.
100,000 GO TO FOUR.
IN NEW YORK IT’S 138.
YOU PUT THEM ON A CHART, YOU
CAN BARELY SEE SOUTH DAKOTA.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR THE
MEDIA SOUTH DAKOTA
APOCALYPSE.
IT’S NONSTOP FEAR MONGERING
MISINFORMATION.
THEY SAID THE NEW HEAD OF THE
HHS CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE TEAM
WAS ELABORATE DOODLE BREEDER.
ELABORATE DOODLE BREEDER IS
CURRENTLY RUNNING THE
DAY-TO-DAY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE TO A ONCE IN A
CENTURY PANDEMIC AT HHS.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING PUTTING A
DOG BREEDER IN CHARGE OF
CORONAVIRUS EXCEPT HE’S NOT
JUST A DOG BREEDER, WHEN HE
CHECKS THE FACTS HE’S AN
EXPERIENCED GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL WITH MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATION’S INCLUDING THE
WHITE HOUSE AND HEALTH
DEPARTMENT, BUT WHATEVER LET’S
JUST SCARE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND SCARE THEM ABOUT NURSING
HOMES.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GO
IN TO HOTSPOTS OR POTENTIAL
HOTSPOTS LIKE NURSING HOMES OR
PRISONS, OR DENSELY POPULATED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND BE ABLE TO
TEST PEOPLE WHO AREN’T SHOWING
SINCE SYMPTOMS.
>> YES, AND THAT’S ALMOST TWO
WEEKS BEFORE YOU SAID THAT,
DOCTOR BURKE SAID THIS.
>> WE WILL BE DOING
SURVEILLANCE THROUGHOUT
NURSING HOMES, THROUGHOUT
INNER-CITY FEDERAL CLINICS,
THROUGHOUT INDIGENOUS
POPULATIONS TO REALLY BE ABLE
TO FIND EARLY ALERTS OF A
SYMPTOM ATTIC INDIVIDUALS IN
THE COMMUNITY.
>> THE WORST DISASTER IN THE
WORLD IN SOUTH DAKOTA, THE
GOVERNMENTS DOING NOTHING, ON
AND ON IT GOES, BUT IT’S ALL
MISINFORMATION AND IT MATTERS
BECAUSE DEMOCRAT LEADERS TAKE
THEIR CUE FROM WHAT THEY SEE
ON THEIR FAVORITE NEWS OUTLET
CNN, MSNBC AND THE REST OF
THEM.
THE MUTUAL APPRECIATION
SOCIETY.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORTING ON THE STORY.
YOU’VE DONE A TREMENDOUS
SERVICE TO US ALL.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
YOU’RE SO MARVELOUS.
THIS MISINFORMATION, THIS FEAR
IS NOT JUST EMPTY WORDS, AND
HAS A REAL WORLD IMPACT.
THE HUMAN COST OF THE SHUTDOWN
PUSHED BY THE SHUTDOWN
FANATICS ON TV.
IF YOU WANT TO OPEN UP YOU
WANT PEOPLE TO DIE THEY SAY.
>> HE’S A FAN OF MONEY FIRST,
MORTALITY SECOND.
>> PEOPLE ARE DYING.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOW
LISTENING TO VOICES ON THE
RIGHT THAT SAY WHAT’S A
MILLION SENIORS WHEN YOU’RE
THINKING ABOUT THE WHOLE
ECONOMY.
>> IT’S A GROTESQUE AND
GRATUITOUS INSULT.
JUST FOCUS ON THE FACTS.
IT’S NOT JUST CORONAVIRUS THAT
KILLS.
THE SHUTDOWN COSTS LIVES TWO.
TWO SENIOR CADETS AT THE AIR
FORCE ACADEMY COMMITTED
SUICIDE WITHIN DAYS OF BEING
QUARANTINED.
OTHER CANCER SURGERY AND LIVER
SURGERY HAS BEEN CALLED OFF.
IN APRIL 1 MILLION HEALTHCARE
JOBS DISAPPEARED.
THE FEAR STRUCK BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT MEDIA ACCORDING
TO THIS DOCTOR HAS LITERALLY
KILLED PEOPLE.
>> MY HUNCH IS THAT IT MAY BE
A GOOD THIRD OF PEOPLE DYING
OUT OF THE HOSPITAL MAY BE
BECAUSE OF PREVENTABLE
ILLNESSES THAT ARE NOT THE
DIRECT RESULT OF THE VIRUS,
BUT ACTUALLY INDIRECT RESULT
OF PEOPLE BEING FEARFUL ABOUT
GETTING CARE.
>> PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING TO STAY
AWAY.
WE EVEN FOUND THAT PATIENTS
WITH STROKE OR HEART ATTACK.
>> AND JUST LISTEN TO THIS
DOCTOR.
>> I’M CALLING AS A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST.
OUR PERCENTAGE OF DEATH IS WAY
LESS THAN .01%.
OUR PERCENTAGE OF GETTING IT
IS A LITTLE BIT HIGHER BUT NOT
MUCH AND WE ARE WATCHING AS
MANY COUNTIES ARE THE
EMOTIONAL TOLL THAT THIS VIRUS
IS TAKING FOR PEOPLE WITH
RISING INCIDENTS OF CHILD
ABUSE AND EMOTIONAL
DEVASTATION.
>> HEART ATTACK, STROKE, CHILD
ABUSE, BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP
GOING WITH THE SHUTDOWN.
HAVE YOUR HEART ATTACK AT
HOME.
I’M SURE YOU’LL BE FINE.
HOW BAD IS A STROKE REALLY, DO
YOU NEED A DOCTOR FOR THAT,
CHILD ABUSE IS A PRICE WORTH
PAYING.
HERE’S THE DISHONESTY.
THEY DON’T EVEN ASK WHETHER
THE HUMAN COST OF THE SHUTDOWN
IS WORTH BECAUSE THEY PRETEND
THERE ISN’T ONE.
STOPPING CORONAVIRUS INFECTION
IS THE ONLY AN ABSOLUTE
IMPERATIVE.
NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
THIS IS WHAT SINCLAIR COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICERS SAID
RECENTLY.
SHE IMPOSED THE NATION’S FIRST
SHUTDOWN HERE IN THE BAY
AREA.
IF WE LIFT TOO SOON, THERE IS
NO REASON TO THINK WE WOULD
HAVE EXPONENTIAL SPREAD.
OUR WHOLE POPULATION IS
SUSCEPTIBLE AND AT RISK.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
WE KNOW FROM THE DATA THAT
OVER 80% OF THOSE INFECTED HAD
MILD OR ZERO SYMPTOMS.
OUR WHOLE POPULATION IS NOT AT
RISK.
BECAUSE OF THIS RECKLESS
MANUFACTURED CLIMATE OF FEAR
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED OF EVEN
CATCHING THIS VIRUS.
THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
AS WE SAID HEAR FROM THE
START, THE FOCUS SHOULD BE ON
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE, BUT
NO, THEY PUSH FEAR AND WE NOW
HAVE A HUMAN CATASTROPHE FROM
THE SHUTDOWN.
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS HAVE
LOST THEIR JOB, THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE, MOST OF THEM BY THE
WAY, THE EXACT SAME PEOPLE,
DEMORALIZING MEDIA GRANT
STANDARDS THAT THEY SAY THEY
SPEAK FOR.
GUESS WHO’S BEING HIT MOST.
HISPANIC AMERICANS.
TURNS OUT THEY’RE THE BIGGEST
THREAT.
BUT YOU, THE FEAR MONGERING
MEDIA, YOUR MISINFORMATION HAS
A HUMAN COST.
IT BREEDS FEAR.
FEARS STOPS PEOPLE FROM GOING
TO THE HOSPITAL EVEN WHEN
THERE ARE EMPTY BEDS.
IT STOPS PEOPLE FROM GOING OUT
EVEN WHEN THEY’RE NOT AT
RISK.
FEAR COST JOBS AND LIVELIHOOD,
BUT IT ALSO COST LIVES SO
PLEASE STOP THIS DANGEROUS
DIVISIVE MISINFORMATION.
I WILL GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD
TO SOMEONE I DON’T KNOW BUT
WHO SEEMS INCREDIBLY SMART AND
BRILLIANT AT WHAT SHE DOES.
>> IF SOMEBODY IS REPEATEDLY
MISINFORMING THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC ABOUT IMPORTANT THINGS
HAVING TO DO WITH THIS
DISEASE, DON’T BROADCAST THAT.
>> TELL US WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL THAT AND SHARE IT